the US is accusing Russia failing to
honor a United Nations ceasefire
agreement in Syria the rebel-held area
of eastern goota near damascus faces
continued minbars meant aid groups are
standing by in humanitarian corridors to
help injured evacuees but so far those
victims have stayed away Seth Doane is
at one of those crossing points just
inside Eastern Gudda he is the only
network correspondent there Seth good
morning good morning this is one of four
humanitarian corridors that have been
set up here to allow civilians in
rebel-held besieged Eastern Goethe which
is just in that direction to come here
into government-held territory you can
see there are ambulances lined up here
there are also buses to help evacuate
people but this is day number three and
as you can see these humanitarian
corridors this one here is empty and
both sides are blaming the other the
government is saying that rebels inside
Eastern goota have held hostage some
civilians there and also that the rebels
are bombing are targeting these
humanitarian crossings the rebels on the
other hand are accusing the government
of making it difficult for them to cross
they say they worried activists inside
worry that they will be arrested once
they make it here it is impossible for
us to cross into eastern goota so we
reached out to one doctor by telephone
to ask him what it was like working
there what is most difficult for you
everything is most difficult strikes
doctor soccer told us that his hospital
has been bombed and since then he has
been performing doing surgeries
underground we asked him why he stays
I want freedom in my home it's my home
meanwhile aid agencies are lined up on
this side the government held side they
say they're ready to go but these five
hour-long humanitarian pauses are simply
not long enough to be effective
Alex Seth Doane in Syria with some
incredible reporting thanks Seth